-Welcome back.
I'm talking with Common.
I always love
talking to you, buddy.
The new Audible original
is available tomorrow.
It's called "Bluebird Memories:
A Journey
Through Lyrics and Life."
Tell me about the concept,
and how would you describe this
to listeners out there?
-Well, I would describe it
as a combination
of theater and live performance.
Because we did it at a theater,
we performed it at a theater,
but it's a written piece.
It's kind of
a new expression from me,
because I wanted to combine
what I do as an actor,
and I've been yearning
to do live theater,
and what I've done as a musician
and a live performer.
So, I came up with this concept
where I wanted
to write a letter to my father,
who passed in 2014,
and the letter would be
a journey through my life
and through my career
and through the music,
but also just who I am
as a human being.
And it would show the laughter,
the good times,
the times I missed him, the
times I might have been angry,
but also just the times we
celebrated and had a great time.
And I really think it's
the journey of a human being,
a man going through life,
and it's told
through these monologues
and through the music.
-Yeah, I loved
in the Audible original,
you talk about your dad buying
your first rap album.
-Yeah, yeah.
That was --
Yeah, so my dad,
he come to town, and he took me
to a record store that we had
in my neighborhood,
called Metro Music.
That's where I would get
some of my music, you know?
And he said, "What do you
want me to get you?"
and I said, "Yeah, can you get
me this rap song right here?
It's called 'The Message,'
by Melle Mel,
Grandmaster Flash,
and the Furious Five."
And he was like, "What?"
You know, like --
'Cause rap wasn't his thing.
He wasn't really too much
up on rap.
He was a doo-wop, a jazz dude.
So he was like, "What?"
And then, you know, hey,
he bought it, he got it for me.
I put it on,
the story goes, man.
I started writing.
Like, maybe two weeks later,
I wrote my first rap, you know?
-That's awesome.
I'm trying to think of my --
the records I would make
my dad get me.
We were into 45s at the time.
-What did you like?
What did you get?
What was one of...?
-I wanted Musical Youth.
"Pass the Dutchie" was my jam.
-Oh, yeah.
-Ooh! Ooh!
I used to love that!
-And he came home, he's like --
Dad's got two 45s,
and me and my sister
are like, "What?! Oh, my gosh!"
And it was "Mandy,"
by Barry Manilow,
and some medley
of The Beach Boys.
And we were like, "Okay."
-[ Laughing ]
Like, again, now I'm older,
and I'm like,
"Oh, they were great jams,"
but I was like,
"Anything on the top 40
that we were pointing out,
we didn't get that at all."
Eventually, I ended up getting
the Musical Youth one,
but I remember it was
Barry Manilow and Beach Boys,
and then I just started going --
I started flipping
through his 45s
and just playing doo-wop,
like you were saying,
or when you get
to hear the drums
on The Rolling Stones
or something like that.
I remember him playing
"Honky Tonk Woman,"
Rolling Stones, and he was like,
"Just watch the woofer
when you put this on,"
and it was like, "Ba bum, ck,
buh-ck, boo boo-ck,"
and you see the thing moving.
I was like, "Whoa,
the speaker's moving.
I didn't even know
it was that --"
But I loved any of that stuff.
-I loved getting introduced
to those things,
but, you know, when you a kid,
you want to hear your music.
Like, I roll around
with my daughter,
I would take her ice-skating
with her friends,
and I remember playing
Lauryn Hill.
She claims
I was playing Michael Jackson,
but I say I was playing
Lauryn Hill, and she said --
she was like,
"Dad, can you put on music
that was made after '98?"
and I was like...
-[ Laughing ]
It happens to generations
and generations.
It's so fun, right?
-Yeah, I'm just like,
"Yo, chill out.
Like, this is classic."
Now she loves Lauryn Hill.
-Yeah, of course.
And I know every doo-wop song
in the world.
Yeah, it's like --
It all --
-Generations.
-Yeah, exactly.
Great catching up
with you, Common.
I love talking to you.
Congrats on
the Audible original.
It's out tomorrow --
"Bluebird Memories:
A Journey
Through Lyrics and Life."
Please come back. I want
to see you in person, bud.
-Yes, I will see you
in person, man. God bless.
Be well, Jimmy, a'ight?
-You too. Bye, bud.